do you have a Tik Tok I do you look like
someone who would have a Tik Tok oh well
that's okay could you show us your best
dance move this is like kind of a quick
one so make sure you're like paying
attention right that's that's as much as
I'm going to do how many followers on
Instagram do you have just like 1,200
not a
lot not a lot at all why should we think
you're cool thank you I think you guys
are cool you guys why why should we
think we're cool what do you like to do
during your free time right now I'm
watching Netflix a lot cuz like the new
one piece thing just came out so so you
like anime sometimes I like the sleeves
thank you guys you have you dyed your
hair I have yes I wish this was a
natural do you ever trip in those pants
I'm just wondering I wor those i' would
be tripping ever surprisingly no because
it kind of like sweeps to the side I
like her outfit three two one a you guys
are sweet that's so nice well at least
you're younger than the previous person